joining me now is Jimmy falia host of
fox Across America you know him hey hey
and I like your suit today although it's
not sparkly uh it rained it in Jimmy
well on Friday mayor Eric Adams he
signed a law Banning discrimination
based on height and weight in New York
City watch this as the chair of the
National Association to Advance fat
acceptance and a co-founder of the
campaign for size freedom I am
so thrilled at the example that New York
City is setting today when you talk
about not discriminating against someone
because of their body type is not
fighting against obesity it's just being
fair
isn't it like a health issue I was just
gonna say that okay I took your joke no
not at all I just mean I should probably
be on their side because I look like I
get paid in mozzarella sticks but to be
clear where you're not a protected class
is against illness okay you're going to
incur higher rates of diabetes and heart
disease and everything in between so
this is a weird battle to fight because
you're actually putting these people in
more Harm's Way by encouraging obesity
are you not I mean we think back to kova
do you remember when they were
incentivizing the vaccine by giving you
a Krispy Kreme donut yes but the number
one cause of kova death was obesity yes
it's like I know these symbolic gestures
sound like they mean well but come on
man it's not it's it's actually not good
and you can say all right we're not
going to discriminate in the workplace
and that's fine but you know what
they're still going to discriminate on
like the boss of the train no one's
happy to see it coming no I don't mean
to say you know what I mean nobody wants
to hear that but no one you never get on
the train and go if only somebody 425
pounds could sit down next to me that's
always my dream someone whose Shadow
once killed a dog could sit next to me
on this coach flight it'd be great you
know what will you get paid in
mozzarella sticks and I get paid in Sean
Hannity Green Room food they always have
the best it's good foods really good
stuff feed you good yes they do Jimmy
the live action Little Mermaid I went
there this weekend and I screamed the
whole time so I only saw half of it it
debuted in theaters this weekend watch
this um
I help them
yes indeed I did see that part that was
before my six-month-old son started
screaming the New York Times though they
were not too impressed either their
review said that the movie reeks of
obligation and Noble intentions Joy fun
mystery risk flavor Kink they're missing
Jimmy
Kink what a weird thing like to put it
in Little Mermaid terms they should have
left that last paragraph Under the Sea
you know what I'm saying because where
are you ever going to be engaged in a
transaction with a child and confidently
say like there should have been more
kink like you know you come home at the
end of the night and the babysitter's
like we had a nice time we could have
used a little more Kink you would have
called the cops you know it was Sean
would have swung at the guy and
rightfully so it's weird that they're so
confident talking in these sexualized
terms around kids but they are for
whatever reason you know it's kind of
gross as a little girl who used to like
sit like cross-legged like singing The
Little Mermaid
um I can tell you it didn't need Kink no
and I know it was wrong and I wasn't one
of those kids that was cute enough to
get flirted with like I never had to
worry and no one ever looked at me oh
Jimmy wrong you're cute especially when
you wear your sparkles hey girl all
right Jimmy you know I was the White
House Press Secretary under Trump and I
have to say this never happened from the
podium
question for you what's your what's your
favorite Beyonce song
answers what answer
okay she asked a reporter for their
favorite Beyonce song as the Playboy
reporter was shouting over me along with
like every other reporter I wouldn't
have had a chance to get questions and
technically they were the one asking the
questions of the screaming tone you know
what I would have loved so much if that
reporter actually she's like what you
bet for Beyonce song and he just opened
a binder and scrolled through it for
like three minutes and was like I've got
nothing I refer you to the Department of
Justice which is what she always does
yes but isn't it so crazy to you of all
people I'm so glad we got to do this to
acknowledge what seems to be a little
bit of a tone shift between White House
Press Secretary for one Administration
and another you know because you would
get I would we would watch you and we
were laughing because it was like
watching like an MMA fight because you'd
just show up and they'd be like what's
it like working for Hitler you're like
oh my gosh they're doing Beyonce they've
got a squad it's crazy and Jen sake is
giving them cookies but we gotta get to
this one okay I know you're well aware
of the Los Angeles Dodgers Pride night
Fiasco but some MLB players have started
to speak out against the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence those sisters who
pole danced around crosses Trevor
Williams of the Washington Nationals he
tweeted this to invite and honor a group
that makes a blatant and deeply
offensive mockery of My Religion
undermines the values of respect and
inclusivity that should be upheld by any
organization we've got 15 seconds go
thank you number one this is not what we
meant when we called for a drag bunt by
the Dodgers but number two like I go to
baseball games with my son we never
leave going you know what this was
missing yeah if someone could just
desecrate the Messiah exactly all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else